allons-y vous avez écrit à propos de
votre grand père à propos de votre père
et maintenant c'est au tour de votre
mère pourquoi elle est le contraire de
notre époque
tout ce que vous pouvez voir sur une
chaîne de télé elle l inverse on est
dans une époque où tout le monde a peur
elle n'a pas peur elle n'a pas peur
d'exister
on est dans un monde de principe de
précaution de 2 l aux 6 et si elle aime
quatre hommes et les installe à la
maison elle court le risque d'être
absolument vrai comment un jeune garçon
de 9 10 ans réussissait à vivre alors
que votre mère avec 4 à main sous un
même toit
c'était vivant parce que je voyais une
femme réelle
il ya plein de femmes qui nous écoutent
qui ont des amants qui les cache qui ne
sont pas réelles elles vivaient dans une
vérité et donc pour un enfant être
confronté à la vérité des adultes
c'était un spectacle inouï
c'était à la fois violent et un
spectacle d'une grande beauté parce que
quand les êtres humains sont vraies ils
sont magnifiques et les maisons des
autres me semblait beaucoup plus
ennuyeuse d'ailleurs mes copains ont
préféré venir chez moi mais y'a pas des
scènes de jalousie ou certaines fortes
intentions
non je voyais ces hommes se battre il y
avait une compétition amoureuse
extraordinaire il essayé de la faire
rire et il l'embarqué
il faisait des choses absolument folle
pour éliminer les autres donc on était
au cinéma
d'ailleurs ça tombe bien puisqu'il
faisait tous du cinéma ils ont en fait
beaucoup de films français des années 70
[Musique]
c'est pas cher aux allées mais je ne
t'appartient pas il marche et cm1 cause
décembre à tous comme il y avait
beaucoup de souffrance
transfiguré dans un culot monument
monumentale et et ce qui est étonnant
c'est que je voyais bien que toutes les
autres femmes à l'époque les copines de
ma mère était interloquée se disait mais
comment fait-elle pour vivre ce à quoi
est ce qui est bouleversant aujourd'hui
c'est que depuis que le livre est sorti
le livre a le même effet quel à l'époque
ce que je vois kilomètres de courriers
de messages que je reçois par les
réseaux des femmes qui se posent des
questions et moi au fait est ce que
j'ose vivre alors c'est extraordinaire
ça va de la femme qui qui referme le
livre et qui quitte son mât est le
ferment un mardi et le kit le jeudi et
le week end après va rejoindre son amour
de jeunesse
au portugal il ya quinze jours et un
homme qui m'envoie un message qui est un
conducteur de métro à paris qui veut
dire je viens dire ce livre je me dis
mais au fond est ce que je vis moi aussi
il était amoureux d'une femme qui
promettent tous les matins il m'envoie
un message et il me dit lundi si elle
est d'ordre dans le wagon je prendrai
mon micro et je lui ferai ma déclaration
d'amour et je lui dirai des poèmes
d'aragon
je pensais pas qu'il le ferait il le
fait toutes les femmes dans la rame ce
sont 10 mai est ce que c'est moi
il a décrit le manteau rouge qu'elle
portait et lui a laissé un livret que le
numéro de téléphone aujourd'hui vivent
ensemble il est conducteur de métro à
paris il a couru le risque de prendre le
et de dire sa vérité
c'est mon choix parce que certains
lecteurs les crocs sur déjà écris pour
vous dire écoutez là votre littérature
en quelque sorte détruit ma vie c'est
déjà passé j'ai reçu la semaine dernière
une enveloppe épaisse gelé ouverte et il
y avait mon livre déchirée en mille
morceaux sans l'être sans explication
est ce que sa femme l'avait quitté je ne
sais pas mais c'est très violent et en
même temps c'est un en même temps c'est
un éloge pas ce que ça veut dire que le
livre a touché quelque chose récemment
je disais certains passages des lettres
d'amour d'un avocat à sa conjointe vers
un avocat qui semblait croire à l'amour
éternel aux grands à voir avec une seule
personne y croyez vous c'est pas que j'y
crois si je ne vois pas comment on peut
s'en sortir sur terre si on n'a pas
accès à un chef-d'oeuvre samsung
invivable si ici un moment ne le trouve
pas ça me son propre nom et vivable et
je ne comprends pas comment autant de
gens ont pu renoncer me paraît fou
littéralement fous de vibrac au nom de
renoncer un amour qui sont un
chef-d'oeuvre absolu
mais on auront vécu qu'autant que nous
aurions aimé l'enjeu est énorme
je veux bien fait des comptes compromis
sur mes couleurs de chemise mais sur ces
questions 2 c'est impossible parce que
le mode de vie de votre mère vous
l'appliquez dans votre propre vie je ne
copie pas ma mère mais je vis avec la
même liberté
c'était là que je dis aux gens de les
choses ce qui est très risqué et
jouissif au final